[Musique]
j'aimerais vous parler d'un sujet que
nous connaissons tous ici l'amour pour
ça j'aurai besoin d'un briquet et
pourquoi d'un briquet et bien comme
l'amour le briquet a besoin de trois
ingrédients pour fonctionner d'abord du
carburant ensuite d'une étincelle
parce que rien ne peut démarrer sans une
étincelle et ensuite il faut fournir un
effort permanent pour alimenter cette
flamme voyez ici nous sommes tous des
briques en puissance
nous possédons tous à réservoir
quasiment inépuisable d'amour et une
fois
l'étincelle de la rencontre passer ce
moment très bref magique
et bien c'est à nous de fournir cet
effort pour pouvoir alimenter cet amour
et braver des perturbations mais est ce
que c'est si simple que ça pas tout à
fait pourquoi parce qu'une étude
statistique de l'insee nous révèle que
environ 46% des mariages en france
finissent par un divorce
c'est quasiment un sur deux oui vous
avez bien entendu un sur deux c'est
édifiant
et pourtant je ne parle que des mariages
si on considère les relations dans leur
ensemble
en fait une statistique de monsieur même
institut nous révèle que la durée
moyenne des relations diminue avec les
générations
je veux répéter la phrase la durée
moyenne des relations diminue avec
génération
vous avez un beau graphique derrière je
vais essayer de vous l'expliquer avec
deux exemples simples des extrêmes
si vous êtes né dans les années 50 est
bien plus de la moitié d'entre vous ont
le couple qui aura persister et rester
il faut se re est resté soudé après 50
ans de vitesse 50 années de vie commune
si vous êtes nés dans les années 80 par
contre c'est une tout autre histoire
parce que plus de la moitié des couples
se sont déjà déliter après seulement
quinze ans si la tendance se confirme je
donne pas chère au couple un nez après
les générations des années 90 si vous en
faites partie ici je vous conseille
d'écouter attentivement ce que je vais
dire
nous avons tous dans notre entourage des
parents et des grands parents qui ont
fêté leurs 30 ans 40 ans 50 ans de vie
commune de mariage comment font-ils
quel est leur secret et puis surtout
nous ici sommes nous condamnés à subir
la dure loi des statistiques
bonne nouvelle la réponse est non et mes
travaux de recherches m'ont amené à
trouver une voix étonnante pour pouvoir
déjouer ces statistiques et reprendre
notre destinée amoureuse en main à ce
que vous voulez que je partage ses
secrets avec vous merci il réside
ce secret il réside dans la modélisation
mathématique des relations amoureuses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rappelons d'abord que les modèles
mathématiques sont des représentations
de la réalité pour décrire des
phénomènes bien précis un exemple qui va
vous parler la météo parade des
équations prenons en compte
l'ensoleillement la température ou la
vitesse du vent eh bien on arrive à
prédire le temps qu'il va faire demain
pour les couples c'est exactement la
même chose depuis plus de 30 ans des
chercheurs tentent d'expliquer comment
prédire la durabilité de nos couples et
parmi les pionniers rinaldi et son
équipe l'ont fait en prenant des
exemples dans les couples légendaires
comme roxanne et cyrano de bergerac
cyrano de bergerac
bien connu pour son long nez est fou
amoureux de roxane roxane m plus tôt
christian de neuvillette au physique
beaucoup plus avantageux mais cyrano
n'abandonne pas et en mettant le talent
de ses mots dans la bouche de christian
il parvient à convaincre roxane que
l'amour va bien au delà de l'apparence
physique
un autre exemple de couples célèbres au
destin funeste l'or et pétrarque
pétrarque
si vous en souvenez est un poète du 14e
siècle
il est tombé sous le charme de l'or mais
l'or est une femme mariée
du coup pétrarque va alterner entre
périodes d'exaltation et de désespoir
exaltation quand ils se sont aimés par
laure et désespoir quand il a le
sentiment de 7,2 d'être rejeté par
l'illustration de cet amour cycliques
rinadh y est parvenu à illustrer
parfaitement la relation du fis moi je
te suis suis moi je te suis la même
équipe
ce mathématicien et son équipe ont
réussi à décrire également née ménage à
trois comment en se servant d'un couple
célèbre que vous connaissez certainement
aussi jules et jim
alors jules et jim et catherine parce
que le titre fait jules et gym mia
catherine catherine est amoureuse à la
fois de jules l'allemand et de gym le
français en mathématiques à ces
relations ce qu'on appelle des relations
à trois ordres sont bien connus pour 7
minet en cao ou dans le cas de jules et
gym en tourbillon de la vie
vous voyez toutes ces histoires sont de
beaux romans de bord de belles pièces de
théâtre de beau film
mais dans la réalité est ce qu'il ya des
résultats
eh bien oui la réponse est oui et c'est
le travail du docteur gottman qu'on
appelle le docteur love qui étudient des
couples réel et qui arrive à prédire que
la durabilité des couples fragile au
bord de la rupture avec plus de 90% de
réussite et ceci toujours grâce à des
équations mathématiques
vous voyez donc que vous aurez quand
vous aurez si vous avez des problèmes de
couple
[Musique]
vous n'irez plus voir le thérapeute re
mais votre mathématicien préférées
évidemment les mathématiciens comment
est ce qu'ils ont fait pour pouvoir
relever ce défi quelles sont ses clés la
laissez moi vous les donner le travail
de rinaldi eux qui a été initié il est
environ 30 ans a fait ressortir trois
paramètres principaux le premier
paramètre c'est le potentiel
d'attractivité que nous avons en nous
nous pensons et je pense que tout le
monde ici le pense au physique tout
d'abord mais ça ça va durer plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois dans la relation
très vite le physique va devoir faire
place à d'autres choses comme le charme
l'intelligence l'humour l'écoutent
en bref soyez créatifs repenser à cyrano
de bergerac pour qui la conquête de
roxane n'était pas gagné du tout
d'accord et bien grâce au talent et au
charme de sa plume
il a réussi à conquérir et roxanne le
deuxième paramètre et l'usure du couple
c'est un phénomène que nous appelons
habituation que nous connaissons tous
quand nous portons un parfum pour la
première fois au bout de plusieurs
semaines on va dire deux trois semaines
vous ne le sentez plus sur vous votre
cerveau et votre corps se sont habitués
à lui est bien pour l'amour c'est
exactement pareil l'habitude va creuser
le tombeau de vos relations
faites attention
un exemple pour voir alors juste les
défauts les petits défauts que qui était
caché par votre aveuglement au début de
la relation vont commencer à sortir
insidieusement par exemple vous ne
supportez plus du tout le bruit qu'il
fait quand il mange ta soupe lé vos
compliments vent se vent devenir de plus
en plus rare pire encore vous n'allez
même plus remarqué les efforts que fait
l'autre pour vous séduire
et c'est réciproque autrement dit à un
moment donné vous allez faire partie des
meubles
troisième et dernier paramètre la
réaction que l'on éprouve face à l'amour
de l'autre basique au début puis tu me
détestes plus je te déteste plus tu
m'aimes plus je t'aime c'est une droite
montante en mathématiques on appelle ça
une relation linéaire elle peut très
vite devenir très compliqué c'est
l'exemple le plus simple c'est celui que
je vais donner tout à l'heure celui de
l'or et pétrarque ou l'or marié et
fidèle aime quand même se faire séduire
et se rapprocher par pétrarque heureuse
de séduire vraiment est justement de se
faire charmer mais pétrarque
se sentant en confiance devant en
insistant lors commence à prendre
panique pour son mariage et pour
elle-même et s'enfuit en laissant
pétrarque complètement pantois et
désespérée mais voyant pétrarque
s'éloigner prise de pitié
l'or va aller le rechercher et revenir
au début c'est à dire aimer se laisser
séduire etc
ce manège va durer vingt ans +33 166
points et un ouvrage
plus près de nous nous avons tous autour
de nous dans notre entourage des amis
des proches ou quelqu un confident qui
est venu nous voir en disant je suis en
relation depuis pas longtemps mais j'ai
déjà souffert et j'ai vraiment peur et
je pense que ça devient trop sérieux et
je pense que je vais m'éloigner et que
ça va pas le faire qu'est ce que vous
allez faire repenser à votre
mathématicien préféré première chose
vous regardez votre ami et vous regardez
les trois paramètres attractivité ça va
encore c'est bon tu peux encore séduire
il ya aucun problème
usure bah ça fait deux mois que tu es en
couple et tu commences à avoir peur
c'est pas tout à fait ce problème là qui
va être la clé troisième paramètre ta
réaction face à moore 2 le face à
l'amour de l'autre et c'est là que vous
allez pouvoir identifier d'où vient le
problème
c'est beaucoup trop compliqué il va
falloir que tu simplifier les choses
vous voyez ces trois paramètres
attractivité usure et réactions ne sont
pas des constante universelle
ces trois paramètres sont propres à vous
à chacun d'entre nous nous sommes tous
différents
nous aimons plaire ou pas faire des
compliments ou pas nos réactions sont
inertes ou pas en bref ces trois
paramètres font de nous des êtres
uniques et nos couples simple ou
compliqué vous voyez l'amour et les
relations amoureuses sont complexes
les mathématiques sont complexes les
deux étaient faits pour s'entendre
évidemment mais ce n'est pas fini parce
qu'il faut qu'on a posé ses par m il va
falloir analyser le problème est pour ça
tout est une question d'équilibré et de
stabilité
notre travail à nous tous sera
d'identifier ces équilibres autour de
notre relation est là je vais vous
donner des équations mathématiques
non je rigole pour être beaucoup plus
clair je vais vous donner un exemple
avec des graphes ça va vous parlez
beaucoup plus considérons deux axes le
premier un axe horizontal l' axe
horizontal correspond au temps à la
durée de votre relation
en dehors
j'espère pas en semaine en moi j'espère
en année donc vous prenez le temps que
vous voulez dans un axe vertical
vous aurez le degré de votre sentiment
amoureux
plus vous allez monter plus vous serez
amoureux jusqu'à atteindre une sorte de
plafond
c'est un plafond parce que même
passionné votre amour est limité
nécessairement c'est physiologique
maintenant supposons que nous descendons
vers zéro qu'est ce qui va se passer
et bien en fait nous allons tendre vers
l'indifférence voire la rupture si nous
sommes lassés de la situation place ont
maintenant une droite horizontale entre
ce plafond et 0,7 droite est très
importante on va l'appeler le seuil et
c'est la clé de votre relation
il va falloir une l'identifier au dessus
c'est une de zone de confort puisque
l'amour va s'épanouir en dessous l'amour
aura tendance à s'évanouir et plus la
barre sera haute
plus ce sera dangereux puisque votre
zone de confort sera petit
imaginez-vous c'est comme des couples
très jaloux une dispute un soupçon de
tromperie et c'est le clash
c'est à dire que automatiquement votre
sentiment descendre à la barre et en
othe vous allez dans la zone à risque et
vous descendez vers zéro avec le seuil
très haut
pas de seconde chance possible le
moindre faux pas et c'est fatal
par contre à l'opposé si la barre ce
seuil est assez bas et bien même une
dispute assez forte vous fera décrocher
mais à une distance suffisamment grande
de ce seuil qui est assez bas et vous
restez dans votre zone de confort et
vous remontez sans effort vous voyez
donc que ce seuil est très important
mais complique ont un peu plus les
choses ce qui est trop simple
cette barre là ce seuil va bouger en
fonction de vos situations
toujours une dispute votre votre
amour-propre et écorché votre confiance
et en est entamée et bien votre seuil va
monter vous avez moins confiance en
l'autre et en même temps votre amant va
décrocher les chances pour se croiser et
à l'est dans la zone de risque vont
augmenter par contre des excuses
sincères une réconciliation et le seuil
va baisser
que faire alors et bien garder votre bar
le plus bas possible pour pouvoir faire
face à toutes les filles vicissitudes de
la vie un peu comme le capitaine d'un
bateau qui tient son compère nay vous
vous allez tenir la barre de votre seuil
le plus bas possible et maintenir le cap
comment est bien en jouant avec ces
trois paramètres attractivité usure
réaction ne soyez pas jaloux votre barre
en sera que plus bas surtout essayer de
relativiser les sujets de dispute et
conserver votre énergie essayer de
comprendre l'autre à essayer de
comprendre la situation pourquoi on en
est arrivé là plutôt que prendre cette
énergie écrit encore plus fort que
l'autre essayer d'avoir de l'empathie
envers l'autre retrouver l'autre
physiologiquement parlant ça oblige il
obligera votre corps avoir des bouffées
d'ocytocine c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'hormone du câlin c'est une hormone
produite par le corps qui va vous aider
à redécouvrir ou à retrouver l'autre et
à l'aimer enfin soyez simple prenez une
réaction la pluie nerfs possible votre
vie faite à la plus simple possible
plus elle sera compliqué plus votre
courbe sera compliqué et plus vous aurez
des équilibres néfaste en ayant une
relation simple vous aurez moins d'
équilibre et vous verrez votre zone de
confort beaucoup plus clairement
et c'est vers celle ci qu'il faudra que
vous vous dirigez vous voyez l'amour est
vraiment comme un briquet c'est une
flamme qu'il faut vraiment entretenir
et ça demande un effort compte quotidien
essayer de travailler justement cet
amour comme une tâche vraiment
quotidienne c'est une reconquête
quotidienne aimer l'autre dites lui de
belles choses donnez lui des compliments
tous les jours mais ne fait pas que le
dire par cellule montrer le jeu vous ai
donné toutes mes clés vous faites ce que
vous voulez mais c'est à vous de jouer
et je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]